what was the most memorable time you've
ever picked your nose in public wow
um I think tonight when we were having
our group shot when was the last time
you got through a maisel premier party
sober I don't think there has been one
where I was sober I mean you know it's
it's a Premiere you're supposed to drink
it's a it's an open bar I don't what are
you supposed to do what was your
favorite moment working with me I took a
picture of he and my son and I said I
now have two sons he had just the right
amount of disdain for me as well as
enormous love which character should be
in a spin-off of The Marvelous Mrs
maisel you know one of the characters
that I think has grown the most
throughout the five seasons and changed
the most is Rose and I actually think
that character would be super
interesting to follow